Bei
7000 jahre alt also
2500 jahre älter als die pyramiden das ist wirklich mehr als ein
ägyptisches französisches forschungsteam hat wohl eine der ältesten siedlung überhaupt im nil delta entdeckt
steinwerkzeuge und keramiken zeugen davon dass dort schon mindestens seit dem fünften jahrtausend vor christus eine
langfristige besiedlung durch menschen stattgefunden haben muss vorläufer der pharaonen krieg zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Die älteste siedlung im nildelta wurde jetzt intel samara entdeckt dass es etwa 140 kilometer von kairo entfernt
konkret fand das archäologie team mehrere gruben gefüllt mit werkzeugen keramik und tierknochen dass es wirklich eine rarität
denn das archäologie team geht davon aus dass diese siedlung etwa
7000 jahre alt ist heißt also dass hier menschen gelebt haben und zwar bereits
2500 jahre
bevor die
pyramiden von gizeh gebaut worden sind die jetzt gefundenen buben samt inhalt sprechen eindeutig dafür dass sich die menschen in dieser region langfristig
aufgehalten haben dazu nadia geht vom ägyptischen ministerium für altertümer vor allem die analyse des
biologischen materials wird uns einen besseren überblick über die besiedlung des nildeltas
und die ursprünge der landwirtschaft gegen
forschungsteams erhoffen sich also durch diese funde mehr über die ersten bauern in ägypten zu erfahren wie genau
können wir uns die ursprünge der ägyptischen landwirtschaft vorstellen und wie waren die
prähistorischen gemeinden organisiert bevor die pharaonische geschichte begann gab es dort schon erste strukturen die auf die spätere entwicklung
des ägyptischen reiches
hinweisen spannende fragen deren antworten noch offen sind den forschungsteams wissen bislang nur sehr wenig über das leben der menschen im alten ägypten
bevor das land durch pfarrer und regiert wurde beispielsweise geht die forschung bisher noch davon aus dass die bauern damals noch keine
bewässerungssysteme hatten und vom niederschlag abhängig waren ebenfalls auch vom nil der wohl eine große rolle beim thema landwirtschaft
gespielt hat denn er sorgte für regelmäßige überschwemmungen die die sonst eher karge landschaft in ein fruchtbares paradies verwandeln
das ägyptische ministerium jedenfalls plant für demnächst weitere ausgrabungen in dieser region dann könnte es sein
dass die forschungsteams vielleicht doch auf künstliche
bewässerungssysteme stoßen und das wäre eine sensation denn erst regelmäßige und reiche ernten könnten zu einem großen
bevölkerungswachstum geführt haben und somit auch für die entwicklung der ägyptischen hochkultur
das wäre jedenfalls der absolute hammer frühere ausgrabung sorgt in dem fall schon einmal für eine überraschung
ebenfalls bezogen auf die vorgänger der pharaonen denn funde haben gezeigt dass auch schon die ägypter vor mehr als
5500 jahren ihre toten
konserviert haben also lange vor dem pfarrer und also erste farbe waren das die hin zur pharaonen kultur geführt haben wir können also sehr gespannt
sein auf die zukünftigen entdeckungen hier geht es weiter dafür draufklicken
mysteriöse entdeckung antike totenstadt in ägypten und wenn er kein video mehr zu diesem und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann folgt
mir auf whatsapp nur da bekommt ihr von mir vor allen anderen das neueste video
ganz unabhängig von der abo box hier auf youtube die bei vielen nicht so ganz perfekt
funktioniert ja dafür draufklicken natürlich auch gerne ein abo da lassen und
genau die glocke nicht vergessen bis dann
bleibt dran